[Música]
revista de prensa iniciamos hoy lunes
rosa pérez más de eeuu con las portadas
francesas tras la primera vuelta de las
elecciones legislativas que fueron ayer
domingo vamos con lemon la cual libera
de liberación y le parisien
buenos días exactamente empezamos por la
mont porque además de esta distribución
territorial de los votos que vemos en
portada su digamos editorial analiza las
razones de este alto nivel de abstención
no la editorial se llama la mayoría es
de los abstencionistas algo que también
han destacan en su titular y en estas
entre las razones que dan para
comprender este alto nivel de abstención
citan por un lado que cuando en 2002 el
mandato presidencial pasó de ser de
siete años a cinco años haciéndolo
coincidir con las elecciones
legislativas digamos que pues la
votación legislativa dejó de verse como
una voto de castigo como pasa por
ejemplo en eeuu no que la la elección
presidencial y la legislativa de medio
término pues estarán separadas por dos
años por lo que digamos puede ser visto
como es un voto de castigo como para
valorar un poco pues la tarea del
presidente y del gobierno bueno pues que
a partir de ese momento cuando coinciden
las elecciones presidenciales y las
legislativas pues se alinea mucho el
parlamento con digamos la fuerza que ha
ganado en las elecciones presidenciales
por lo que la gente dejó de comprender
un poco el contrapoder que puede suponer
el legislativo precisamente no por otro
lado dice que el propio macrón no ha
dinamizado esta campaña digamos con un
exceso de confianza en que su perfil
digamos de votante las élites y la gente
mayor digamos son los primeros que se
movilizan para ir a votar y también
critica duramente este editorial del
mont la posición que ha adquirido macrón
frente a la votación en las
circunscripciones donde a la segunda
vuelta ha pasado un candidato de la nube
la nueva unión popular ecológica y
social la unión de las izquierdas frente
a un candidato del partido de marie le
pen agrupación nacional de la extrema
derecha dice que macro no está llamando
a hacer barrera frente a la extrema
derecha como si pidió en la segunda
vuelta presidencial cuando pidió a los
electores de izquierda que lo apoyarán
para no permitir que marín de llegara a
la presidencia dice hacer esto es negar
los valores democráticos que dice
defender y es que me han hablado de
puedes analizar cada circunscripción
caso por caso bueno la croix dice nubes
la nueva unión popular ecológica y
social y ansa la plataforma de macrón
codo con codo no como decías veintiún
mil votos de diferencia liberación dice
izquierda el regreso con fuerza y
destaca que el ministro de educación
michel blanquer el ministro de educación
en el último en el primer y último
mandato de macrón pues ha sido eliminado
en primera vuelta no será diputado igual
que eric de moore el candidato
presidencial de extrema derecha que fue
muy mediatizado también mediapart por
otro lado pasamos si kieres al segundo
dlc pues le parisien dice prácticamente
lo mismo ahora si pasamos entonces
analiza rosa como ven los resultados en
medio media parte señala básicamente que
en la mayoría de circunscripciones en la
segunda vuelta se va a enfrentar un
candidato de la mayoría presidencial
frente a un candidato de izquierdas que
ahí va a estar la clave del parlamento
para saber si macrón va a continuar con
mayoría absoluta en el parlamento o no y
que claramente macrón eso si va a
necesitar pues a la derecha tradicional
digamos para su gobernabilidad y que
puede acabar pues absorbiendo un poco al
partido republicano cambiamos ahora el
tema rosa porque el kiev publica una
entrevista de la agencia afp a mijail
kasyanov quien fue el primer ministro
vladimir putin entre el año 2000 y el
año 2004 exactamente y cuando putin
digamos lo despidió se convirtió casi en
un gran opositor dice que él como la
mayoría de rusos no creían en que fuera
a haber invasión que no se dio cuenta de
que putin tenía intención de empezar la
guerra en ucrania hasta que vio la
escenificación del consejo de seguridad
tres días antes de esta invasión señala
que ucrania no debe exceder territorio
para poner fin a la guerra que si
ucrania cae los estados bálticos van a
ser los siguientes así así también
seguimos en rusia porque ayer la nueva
cadena porque sería de los antiguos
locales de mcdonald's rosa como abrió
esta porque sería pues como señala el
moscú times dice el final de una era los
mcdonald's de rusia reabren bajo un
nuevo nombre y un nuevo logo y es que
después de que mcdonald anunciarán su
partida de rusia por protesta digamos
con la invasión rusa de ucrania alexandr
govern un empresario ruso con
importantes negocios sobre todo en
siberia adquirió los 850 locales que
tiene mcdonal's en rusia les cambió el
nombre por delicioso y punto pero
digamos que mantenido más o menos se
mantuvo más o menos los productos y
también a los 62.000 trabajadores de
mcdonald's por al menos un período de
dos años ayer domingo abrieron 15 de
estos locales hoy lunes abren a 50 otros
locales con la perspectiva de que esta
semana se abran unos 100 y así hasta
reabrir los 850 dice porque pretende
incluso pues abrir más locales de esta
nueva cadena pero simplemente destacar
que trascendió la protesta de un chico
en la inauguración de un mcdonald's en
moscú con una pancarta diciendo
devuelvan el 'big mac' algo que como
discutíamos antes puede ser interpretado
de forma muy literal o puede ser también
visto como una digamos protesta contra
la guerra en ucrania cambiaría el 'big
marc' turís hamburguesa rusa rusa bueno
uno tiene que saber elegir entre las
posibilidades que tiene narrador yo me
quedo con mcdonald's me encanta rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces como siempre
por toda la información de esta revista
de prensa nueva mañana con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado